you
you
what is up everybody how's it going I
hope everyone is having a good day today
I'm pretty excited because we're gonna
be playing a spongebob battle for bikini
bottom
rehydrated this is my very first time
playing the game touching the game I
played the original way back in the day
when I was little I was like 11 or 10 I
remember playing the game but it was so
long ago I felt like I forgot a lot of
parts of it so I thought this is coming
out which is really exciting and the fun
addition actually comes with a bunch of
cool stuff when I started seeing the art
prints that come with this is when the
nostalgia was starting to kick in and of
course like the trailer and stuff so I'm
actually excited to just try out the
game see what it's like because all I
remember from it was like a long time
ago really it makes me feel kind of old
but it's all good because I used to love
spongebob very much I literally had to
call my mom and tell her the game was
coming out and that we did like a little
video call and she's still I very much
respect her she still kept my spongebob
trying from when I was a little kid
intact all my posters and my stuffed
animals that instead of actually hanging
out with the stuffed animal I just hang
it on the wall so now I have some a new
shrine an adult's more sophisticated
shrine I can start with the figures
because all this comes the fun addition
that figures these really nice socks and
I kept these intact for today but after
this I'm definitely wearing those we've
got the Tiki keychains and then these
stickers are already all over my house
these are just a few but the fun
addition that comes with a ton all right
enough I want to play I almost started a
game and I saw like the fade into the
intro see and I was like nope turn it
off I don't want to see it I want it to
be fresh so let's do this I'm excited to
play a new game starting fresh right
here
we didn't see anything anyways I may
move the mouse out of the way I've come
to Bikini Bottom peaceful undersea
sanctuary today it will be transformed
into a theta F Buick I'm wearing a
little yellow friend we play the stereo
[Music]
I have to buy an ingenious plan to
finally steal the krabby patty formula
and if Bikini Bottom happens to get
demolished in the process one last
review of the checklist which item
number one is plankton a genius answer
yes okay checklist complete throw at the
switch my script
Hey
what do you think you doing
[Music]
we're ready in an odd way well I'm your
master by Bejo
[Music]
[Applause]
another playing robots and racehorses
robots to play with Patrick jr. aren't
we going to say the magic wishing words
you're so okay is the magic listen would
it used to be I like a solid alibi
Louise that ticket on a push bar
griddled mitzvahs Vitas no sir but I
kept forgetting it
are you sure there's a work sure last
week I only had one big cookie crumb and
I was really hungry so I put my cookie
crumb in the magic worship shell then I
said the magic wishing word and in the
next Melanie
[Applause]
gonna play with robots gonna play with
robots gonna play robots gonna play with
Wow
Oh Gary did you do that how dare he
blame Gary how dare you believe me yeah
Gary it sure looks like we're in a doozy
of a pickle I think I'm gonna have
everyone in order to fix this mess okay
man a fantastic idea these signs will
provide important tips to help me out um
how do I read the signs oh okay
press this button to read the sign so if
I want to come back in here again just
walk up to you and press this I don't
know I'd better get started up oh my
gosh
the throwbacks the Nostalgia oh my
goodness
okay we are in the house they want me to
read Chris have you guys seen speed
rooms of the original pretty
mind-blowing I make myself a snack
oh my goodness
I'd like I'm taking my sweet time right
now I'm gonna enjoy this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
may see how well he is doing by pressing
right trigger hmm the number in the
upper right is how many shiny object
spongebob has a number in our first
Center this how many golden spatulas
spongebob has elected and the number and
the lower right is how many a Patrick
lost socks sponge uptown and finally the
number in the upper left is how many
parrots my underwear spongebob has
because right you can't forget the
underwear kiss again sorry we got three
birds Endura that's pretty good it's
pretty good start
he's got ample amounts Troy okay but
that's also good although we could pick
that up off the ground
[Music]
ahoy there spongebob as a faithful
service decree you've been promoted to
head trainee object collector promotion
so what does here new job entails is you
collecting all these shiny objects that
the robots are leaving behind and
bringing them to me like crab nose mr.
Krabs knows more about these robots all
right before we do all right
so I'm checking our staff here we have a
54 which means we're good I really want
that
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
oh I guess I should have read that
before I grab a spatula babe we know we
need to collect those guys
I love the organization though there's
nothing like the sounds of your food
maybe they got a pan in on the gold and
undo that there's no way spongebob
you're polluting my thinking space don't
disrespect fun trying to steal the
krabby patty formula again egg carton
well you won't get away with it I've got
bigger fish to fry I've gotta figure out
how to regain control of the Chum Bucket
from those yeah not for me no that's for
sure they just showed up out of nowhere
and started calling me rude names and
throwing things they even been told my
spoons
those foods like they will buy children
Oh help but wait I'm supposed to collect
a whole lot of golden statue golden
spatulas a spongebob if you won't get me
back into the Chum Bucket I'll give you
a bucket full of golden spatulas in your
dreams don't leave a deal
spongeBob is always falling for this
nonsense
Oh rady oh by the way guys these little
tiki hands right here in the funny they
have old old Tiki heads they're super
cute
all right look at mr. Krabs laughing
robot crisis is making the Krusty Krab
lose money like a sinking ship
no money means no more Krusty Krab
no more LT Krabs means no more fry
cooking fries you have to respect
SpongeBob's dedication to his craft but
because you're gullible laughs I'm gonna
help you out and of course make a small
profit in return of course I've got a
few golden spatulas that I'll be willing
to trade to you for some of those shiny
objects
[Music]
whoa buddy you're going to need to learn
some new bubble-blowing moves
if you're going to journey to the ninth
dimension and defeat the giant monkey
man exactly but if thou I need to do is
figure out how to get rid of these
robots oh I've been in the soap bottle a
little too long that's something about
new bubble moves new bubble moves
give me my little spinny with it press
this button and you'll launch yourself
straight up in the air with bubble power
that defeats anything that is like a
light rescue this time out all right
yeah and then there's okay
thank you don't forget to defeat robots
or tikis that are directly above you
press this button
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh I forgot that one explodes
oops it's fine it's all coming back it's
all coming back to me
[Music]
Oh drat about these little things
there's also stuff I think in here that
is restore if I was look at that from
the fun edition details is portions of
the game here that are restored from the
original art and the original anymore
there's also obviously looks much better
there's also a couch co-op and an online
once cleared a lot dated excuse and like
a horde mode I'm definitely the type of
resin that needs to destroy everything
okay oh wait the old bubble buddy help
me out don't forget to defeat robots or
two okay
oh man I thought they disappear when I
get close okay and I'm a wimp for the
expanse but in the meantime yeah they
all saw the couch co-op mode like word
mode play no and there's a built-in
spatula I remember oh there's only one
way up I was chilling in one play I
think
[Music]
man just sometime one second love this
doll today have to patch it
hey Patrick nice knock-knock
one you're standing on right here except
definitely gonna dirty of it well if
that one's lost where are your other
side is there more lost I could use some
help getting them back sure thing
Patrick what are best friends for
okay them forever eatin bring back to me
I'll give you five bucks for them you
got this one out there and finally your
socks you guys alright gold nice edge
Allah bless you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
not quite
I'm trying to remember if I remember
anything else
area pretty much for anything I really
remember was that there with a spatula
up there aside from that oops
famous aside from that yeah almost
Christina fish
[Music]
all right let me check my status here
I've got two spatulas I need 15 of those
five ways to get over there so we can go
this way because there's an ovary
yeah and you already know okay so this
punishing comes with all these fingers
and the first thing I did literally take
a bunch of jellyfish and put it on my
windows over there and sometimes because
they have like the clear background on
the stickers it's not like a white
background so when you put on the window
[Music]
realizing you're done for thing even the
robots laughing at him Squidward are you
okay no I'm not okay you don't worry I'm
okay
Wow your nose I'm using it because it's
usually pretty big but now I'm stung
well according to the jellyfish er Field
Manual of your jealously treated
effectively by applying a thick layer of
King jellyfish jelly to the affected
areas well I guess you're off the scale
sport mountain and officious tentacles
of King jellyfish I'll stay here balled
up here in excruciating pain hey you do
that don't worry Squidward I'll bring
back that King jellyfish jelly for you
to rub all over yourself
all right I love it okay yes my side I
very much appreciate the toons
oh I think once a filly fish has learned
let me read this this is gue
so don't let them fall in got it oh man
but I really want that stock over there
for my homie Patrick that's bad about
killing a belly fish I feel like a new
sponge thank goodness damn all these
clean undies it this is imagination like
Oh
[Music]
lab opening presents did I accidentally
before I go in the Telfer box
I must man that robot he did not have a
good day for I go and about it right now
and 202 rebuild the bridge ah I will
oh my gosh I'm missing oh I'm back wait
wait no mi sister hold up hold up hold
up one thing for me bristling with
platformers I've always just been bad at
it's just like my depth perception
oh wait I'm full and full of undies all
right he's poor jellyfish I'm gonna go
through the teleport box before I go and
I was great
[Music]
Hey Oh relax relax buddy I'm exploring
okay hello hello
okay hey doc for the brother Audrey
oh okay cold spatula down there
let's come back to them let's come back
like I said I remember playing this game
and I think even my mom said when they
were moving some stuff around and like
putting some stuff up away they found
the old piece no I did mess up a sign
with a jump on those boxes first the
order of operations go the box so a lot
of stuff is super familiar but each and
every exactly the wait let me today not
activate something directly wait let's
read the instruction oh I have to open
the other one duh
come on it's not gonna be that easy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah oh wait oh oh
[Music]
[Music]
checkpoint that was a fast bridge build
right there got order
[Music]
oh man I'm ready to attempt to dodge
[Music]
robot baby I almost mess up good thing
fifteen my depth perception
[Music]
easy crew
only Patrick's music excited fan B
because so I feel like growing up I kind
of always resonated sandy a bit more
being from Texas
I am psychic bullet
I feel like I almost I left too much of
an issue all right hey Gary what's she
doing over here tell me about it Wow a
bungee jump for us golden spatula I must
be wengie dumb
[Music]
it's like the fishhook so funny
I always thought that episode was so
clear he goes in there trying to get
Patrick to stop going onto the fishhook
alright let's do it let's do it
wait wait wait it's right there no
alright cuz I got I didn't jump into the
pit earlier all impatient
[Applause]
all right one a massive wedgie later we
have a golden statue
I'm s l'm
[Music]
I experienced a fine push/pull dough
very little speed run jump figure that
out I wonder how fast someone all right
now we've got fundamental day balance we
know how to avoid the spacing don't
worry I got you bud okay sorry
[Music]
let's see we came from that direction
this does go down but I don't think
there's anything of importance over
there
yeah so you feel yeah I almost have a
straight
all right I probably shouldn't be
trained like every little thing if we
wanna see more
[Music]
I'm like anxious for when I'm surrounded
by robots and I'm just mashing little
spin move and hope so I just get
everybody cannon they're playing those
poor pufferfish get abused like bungee
jumping a spongebob
[Music]
women convinced me right
[Music]
I didn't open the other box yet actually
all right we're going this way
come on need to nail the bubble bowling
moving right amazing man bubble buddy
where you at bubble buddy
[Music]
come on bubble buddy I need that bowling
move super combo this ham over here oh I
thought I read one of those already
waves of goo not get out of here it's
you and this is the originator of being
hands right here if you didn't know now
you know too slow oh yeah there we go
oops let me see it
now I think I'm too far to talk to local
people that talk to them back in bikini
bottom
okay okay cyclist hit the first one into
the other ones with my angle oh okay
yeah yeah see you hit one no like not
going to the other ones even though I
took a trade they're both fine let me
take those trades that's why I have a
pair of fresh I'm going to be like a new
- Oh Patrick socket some of them like it
over there oh I got a couple of got a
lot of Patrick sock is up there too weak
that's the bsut we don't get Oh clamber
we don't just leave the BFS sock came
inside right there we don't leave the
best friend socks when we can easily
okay big goodness that last one the Auto
jumps for me because alright see you
back oh it takes me only back
yeah okay continue I thought I saw
another flower but I did darn it let's
keep it moving because I think we can
get to that side once we open this great
shark
[Music]
hold up hold up
[Music]
or was I up there already and I didn't
even realize
[Music]
what I'll do it's a little short in
there
thank you okay yeah
[Music]
maybe that one and then have to be here
besides on you
[Music]
okay I did see the other floating tikis
over here my other guest scientists the
jumpers no that was a stretch to know
when I play most platformers I miss
College that's the way let me try to
open the door now
oops oh man I went all the way back
forgot
walking backwards alright let's go open
that door
I can probably jump across you over
there and I just made my life but it was
worth a shot right
or if you remember
I felt like I got up there alright let's
open this bad boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please save my game I need to see the
progress every time yeah oh wait no
unless it takes me your comics no what
was I supposed to tell you gonna be me
surrounded by robots and needs my help
oh no I think it had something to do
with massaging my feet
well if massaging your feet will say
Patrick then massage I must put a
fulsome guy your feet better try a more
direct approach and then we get to play
slipping my toenails oh the other music
change
[Music]
know that genuinely scared me I didn't
just act like I didn't just get
jumpscared plan he's unreachable
impossible
maybe these switches will create away
the robots are guiding the heavily now
we got this you have to battle through
I'm sorry they just added with faint
music yeah oh oh okay okay
that's meta sponge na no no wait I gotta
get over here first
nah get out of here I got it oh it's
closing great now we got all these hands
over here
[Music]
okay I got scared I thought I missed but
we'll be safe over here
pushing a simple button is the most
satisfying push push push push
hey I like pushing buttons - oh I was
trying to style so that's what I get
that's what I get all right we've got
one more no get away these anywhere boss
over here
[Music]
you know you know I'm gonna nah okay
let's go defeat oh my gosh every villain
goodness you're safe Patrick they said
he's unreachable of course works for
well the robot mmm oh yeah I found this
for ya it is but it looks important man
Patrick he's so cute and deep areas
little blingy animation sweetie this is
a throw fruit
Patrick can pick up throw fruit and
throw them press the beach to pick up
nearby throw fruit and then press B
again to throw it get it throw fruit can
push buttons too straight tikis and
damaged robots got it but use it quickly
because the throw fruit wilts after a
few seconds and look at this sweet so
these figures actually in the fun
edition are three there's three separate
ones so some trick he has some cool
fruit with the underwear on it and it's
so cute
and I because I don't think I practice
oh I'm gonna drop my socks but look
these socks too please figure that real
quick this is the Spongebob one and they
all fit right next to each other when
you put them the spatula actually comes
off and you can like take it out of his
hands yeah super cute put that back
where it rightfully belongs and then I
mentioned earlier how from sexes so I
always resonated that was sandy and then
yeah sandy we got the lasso out and her
little helmets together so I'm getting
one back right there so we can get on
with it
I just have to show that because now
that I'm throwing fruit with Patrick you
can see his whole statue whoa sorry I
hit the mouse since this is on pc down
inside of the mouse
alright so let's throw some fruit
[Music]
women he has a little belly flop like
attack can also pick up and throw TVs
which I clearly tried all of them
showing nothing but you can also pick up
infinity games but only TVs that don't
have other you can stock up all right so
solo teepees I can throw me some solos
[Music]
acceptance respectful ooh but stop be
something all right yeah the bus stop is
where we switch between characters so
I'm gonna rock out with Patrick man why
did I destroy those bathrooms I think I
need it at all hold up
[Music]
brilliant magic it guys like head tilt
forwards if I can pull this map oh
there's nothing like Erica I didn't see
it the first time even though it's
ginormous
[Music]
I forgot it didn't blow up immediately
[Music]
that sounds make me feel so accomplished
- don't you feel sick I don't care you
take those so you take those wait I want
to flex my muscles wanna flex my
accuracy even though it's definitely
Auto luck
I don't care I take all day boom
[Music]
all right so now we're gonna catapult oh
yeah oh look it's a little star on the
plane don't be near it when it goes I
feel like they want me to throw it oh I
didn't realize that I was posting such
as yeah cuz this kindly honestly I can't
let you go like throw it throw it but I
literally just threw it Oh what's up
Bubba Oh where's my stuff over there boy
[Music]
okay having a great time
he's talking to me Oh buddy wrote about
your command down here you're free
Pinker onyx Oh
either mr. plankton are you going to be
today so unfortunately I found myself in
the undesirable position of having to
assist you I was in an undesirable
position yesterday until my dad boots
heed my words my large future minion go
into jellyfish cave follow the
instructions on the signs that you see
at the end of the caves you'll still be
a big pink in the Chum Bucket
oh then will you vaporize me I might
save your life so I can force you to
work in my sweatshop making low quality
designer knockoff wallets if you jump in
the air and press the magical slam down
to the ground damaging tikis or pressing
them
[Music]
all right we've got the accuracy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're Swift I don't know why I got
scared like I thought the watermelon was
gonna blow up and damage me but
oh whoa whoa
I know they're gonna automatically like
float towards me but I still I still
wait to make sure that no I was like you
know in the groove sometimes in life we
can go that flower scared we can just
flow down its place right like a square
there oops
Oh No okay after you really use all that
no lip girl talk too much
let me get past the spikes of dead got
it oh no an idea why do they distract
[Music]
all right you can also jump on throw
fruit to get hired
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah oh they just mean like I was an
additional little stool I don't know why
in my mind I was picturing it would have
like a trampoline effect why don't
forget every
[Music]
we're on the way to death row that okay
nope she did it again
I took let's step two too much for it oh
man okay okay okay
take three three times you're gonna
confirm and throw let's not be even
crazy here oh no now I'm panicking no
not like this alright oh my god yeah
it's not let's not be there we go have
some some grace
your life right calm and collected oh
[Music]
sorry I almost got magic through that oh
[Music]
they're just living our life this is a
crazy fruit okay
gosh yeah raisins of you so we can watch
over it belly flop
wait I'll uh I guess even a friend good
song to stuck on the ground
I love it we'll beat up
[Music]
[Music]
okay that is a pretty wide radius
[Music]
the power of the belly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I need you throw up groups make it no
okay so I can freeze you but is there
anything down here let me go try this
frizzy goo before I go too far even
though it just looks like it's I think
that was everything oh there's one over
there
all right so let's take the watermelon
have to be aware
I don't want I'm gonna hit that thing
over there
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait no I don't know nothing happened
absolutely nothing
maybe I should read the sign again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right buddy come to me instead
listen let me go get these Indians how
many times I failed at throwing and
studying their robot
[Music]
wrong - jellyfish leaks
remember that for later yes I am looking
for the key Joey dude
good thing - that monster has been
stinging oh my good customers and their
poop decks Mountain here go up that
beast sailor oh poor mr. Krabs
[Music]
all right look we got new robots now
platform to take us back to Genesis
games but I activated something
now they're gonna say keep their Goethe
look at this do you see this the target
practice doing the target practice on us
right now
well anything dang
alright yeah that's how you feel that's
how you feel yeah easy spinnin his old
little gun around shoot me you know we
arty arty good MVP
[Music]
[Music]
Amos bucks
Oh mrs. Bob hello Patrick I've got a job
for you to do I found a golden spatula
but those robots out on the island stole
it and threw it into the lake if you can
learn how to get it back you're welcome
to it wait Patrick actually the best all
right showing up mrs. Puff's let's go
let's go Patrick
you know last such practice when a while
but your baby
[Music]
I have to be sneaky wait come on IV
sneaky enough we have all done left or
push the left sugar that's it let's
agree there is no difference Sydney oh
no it's okay I'll find something to
throw let me go help mrs. clump showing
us this pup may not get distracted here
they're giving me a lot of lives
[Music]
so good the robot so it's like those I
guess see and they threw it into fashion
Oh
[Music]
I guess I couldn't go those robots know
when our spatulas in the lake
[Music]
[Music]
oh they saved me again I think I'm like
accidentally
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe it's a fun evening let me go to
bus stop maybe's Patrick he doesn't know
how to do the labels oh all right evict
we're gonna well it did say Patrick can
throw things so I guess that was what
they meant my life make sense make sense
he can be sneaky
he just a brute you know
[Music]
yeah
I seems like citizens are just the heat
group
yo that's Trey I enjoy the strut I was I
was getting too careless oh dang guy
who's dancing in the flames if that
explosion
oh my god and cut about oh wow he really
almost did that lab opening presents I
don't think I'm supposed to destroy
those so come back later when he knows
the crews bubbleman's I am I need to go
see I need to go seeds bubble buddy I
need go see because I feel like a new
desire to move
[Music]
I'm trying to remember if oh yeah let's
all go for it no no I didn't open the
other box yet put the first chance
where's easy chance we get to go back
[Music]
oh I was I was admiring the water bowl
the disrespect I forgot
no I just like doing way too much
[Applause]
Oh No okay I'm one unbe oh is this my
ticket back I thought it was faking the
camera change but that was just me
walking forward
[Music]
well looks let me get around without the
move
[Music]
I mean how did that I knew I only have
one deal of ice bundle and you know it's
there would be no please
oh there's watermelons up here I like
that hold on Oh see my depth perception
[Music]
you're Johnny oh yeah
go get on the wall
[Music]
like a new spot so I just kind of like
this animation mischief mischief ease up
dude
[Music]
[Music]
No
I don't want to jump into it huh yeah
get out here got a frizzy goo but I'm
not Patrick I notice from this level
there was a lot of watermelons and a lot
of a lot of stuff for Patrick so I'm
wondering any guy should have oh okay
that wasn't so bad I guess I just have
to go back around oh no whoa
I'm this Olive Alyssa at least he didn't
die I feel so bad
I really need to go see bubble buddy
though because I have a lot of flowers a
lot of shiny and I think I can
definitely upgrade some new moves
the second I meet up with all the buddy
again bubble buddy so cool go ahead oh
[Music]
my goodness
[Music]
no gonna just raise that my check wait
wait where I'm all the way back over
here Oh
[Music]
no no try to speedrun this whole bed and
get back to where we are wait yeah haha
let's rusty her okay let me stop messing
up this junk holding me back
I gotta get this back up up okay
[Music]
no my biggest downfall clinic on the
clock room again shipping at the wrong
time with okay
[Music]
believe it or not I'm I feel really
doing
it's
[Music]
okay so I'm going to
[Music]
me to go from distance
[Music]
holy that was scary oh it's so active
hey loving him yeah have your left I'm
running away I'm not gonna deal with
your bullying right now I'm already
having over guys get in the box
I thought he was gonna kill amber on
that lunch
he's an odd flavor is it fun I need to
accurately clear the jump if I was
Patrick right now I think I would have
be able to like belly the rest of my way
over
oh man okay let's see no I wish I could
go back onto this oh man oh you know
what I need use Allen I forgot about
that
that was my I in no way blame force fun
fun for me forgetting about my upward
stuff ever got me good but now wait let
me test something okay so I can't I
can't jump jump oh I hit the wrong
button
no all right well write science with
this size or that we're actually gonna
get it at least the music is keeping me
cheerful
maybe I shouldn't jump maybe I should
just do the wine the upward stress
[Music]
I might make it I don't know it's gonna
be tough let's see oh alright I'm just
I'm missing something here I'm missing
let's try the bus stop is so far though
I was gonna say leash is back
[Music]
[Music]
I can't get this high like a spring
break
oh thanks again for it we're gonna jump
over there yeah it was off the trick
okay the wall jumps I remember this I
remember the wall jump and there's bus
stop right there alright so um they
actually just tripped me I'm gonna do
the wall jump
cuz I remember and I definitely was
running on that whole thing please me
I'm just trying to save our citizens
[Music]
this way okay jellyfish is just up at
the top of this path
good luck you'll need it thanks bubble
but wait now I'm sure that you're ready
to tackle King jellyfish not really but
I feel like there's some other moves you
should be teaching me I forgot when you
see a moves but oh yes let's do it
I guess
[Music]
are you sure that you're ready to go I'm
bubbly I need those news I need all the
help I can get
[Music]
[Music]
yes spongebob why are you being a
peeping tom besides I got our own oh
okay okay so clearly I can't hit him
I believe Oh too soon too soon okay okay
I know I know I know be patient
there we go yeah he dropped some
underwears oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
he's got some
babies come after eat we're good we're
good we're good
he's too slow and okay oh oh
do that so I can run too far finish
finishing flap oh okay I see I don't
never like manners sponges I feel like a
new sponge
no ominously floating faster a little
faster that's fine you're and they're
kicking it up a notch no no I jumped so
early yeah right there why did I do
bubble buddy I don't want to talk about
it bubble buddy all right I don't
nothing happened
okay got an extra pair of undies there
no no get him outta here
it
being easy we're gonna get the three in
a row right now right now finishing slap
gonna send the blue boys out
[Music]
yeah Wow
this shower would be an amazing swimming
pool actually see that room feels good
all right bubble buddies so down here no
bubble birthday nicely done little
yellow
[Music]
is there another door on the other side
of this you keep going this way
[Music]
aha hidden box yeah hey there it looks
like you'll have to make up at the end
of that ramp in order to reach that
golden spatula wow that's a mighty big
leap I hope I can make it
Percy these jellyfish
oh she's chillin
[Applause]
- yeah so
[Applause]
[Music]
wait a second oh okay okay okay there it
is
I was like I clearly like a spring green
my spit the spatulas tongue oh oh gosh
I'm a daddy I'm ready I'm ready
whoops thank you lick in the sand where
where I'm up and out I'm sorry I
shouldn't jump into those clearly I
should just try to I don't know I think
I just need to avoid them all together I
don't think there's a graceful way to
not fall off not go into the know zone
was I not supposed to jump
oh no personal space I'm just tryna get
back up there and do that I gotta get
this Goldman smash that's a wrap nah I
gotta get the gold fashion at least I
can go back and get all the things I
miss I'm literally just three destroyed
spongebob in one go what is me my dad
spongy boy I'm just gonna avoid together
I'll lose China you know maybe jump by
them and graze them and to set up
clothing
[Music]
we're not gonna fall off track
and we're gonna get this out I'm gonna
knock press anything and see Oh huh we
had to see the jump at the precise time
we're gonna get you're going to get this
if it's the last thing I do on this
thing with brother look it's why we're
gonna get it we've got this
okay bring it around down
and let's jump and jump again I thought
I was just gonna like jump for me
automatically super lazy thinking but we
got it now let's go back to bikini
bottom
bowling we can even run like oh wait
we're not even if it moves us up the
start of the stage but we can go back
from here I didn't get mrs. Puff's
spatula Lincoln I'm definitely gonna be
like 100% this game finding it a go
times a bubble bunny because I got lots
of timings um yeah
to defeat robots or TV
[Music]
all right you guys well that was super
fun and I really enjoyed it so far it
was like total nostalgia trip I also
forgot a ton of stuff so it still feels
fresh to me even the baby and he's just
so adorable I'm sorry I'm obsessed with
funny pop I can't contain it don't know
what to tell you other than chilling so
I hope you guys enjoyed the street I
hope that if you like what you saw today
you consider getting it they also have
the fun addition which is available now
it comes with these awesome figurines I
was showing up earlier in the stream
some for 5tp keychains and match all the
teepees at you you know destroy in the
game also comes with six separate word
prints and B is amazing socks so awesome
stuff you guys if you're interested
check it out hope you enjoyed this game
hope you enjoyed the stream and see you
next time thank you guys so much and
have a good one peace
you